Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Klasik müzik başlar)
(Klasik müzik sona erer)
Herkese merhabalar,
ben Ziya Azazi.
Suriye kökenliyim.
Terzi Hasan ve ev hanımı Emel'in oğlu,
on yedi yaşında
İstanbul'a Teknik Üniversite'de
Maden Mühendisliği okumak üzere geldim.
Yirmi dört yaşında Avusturya'ya geçtim,
oradan da diğer ülkelere.
Ve oradan Belçika, Almanya ve
İsviçre'de çeşitli projelerde sahne aldım.
Yani kısaca, ömrümün ilk otuz yılı
aslında bir çöp misali, dünyanın içinde,
farklı yerlerde çalkalandı gitti.
Bilinçsizce gidildi.
Yeri gelmişken bu yüzden aslında
boyutları bir şekilde ima etmek istiyorum.
Nokta, bildiğimiz gibi boyutsuzluğu;
çizgi, tek boyutu;
düzlem iki; küp üç; zaman da
dördüncü boyutu tarifler.
Herkes bilir.
Bizler de üç boyutlu yaratıklar olarak
dördüncü boyutta hareket ederiz
ve ölüme doğru evriliriz.
Özetle aslında hikâye bu.
Ben de, böyle bir noktacık olarak,
evrende önce Türkiye'de
sonra diğer ülkelerde evrildim
otuz yıl, ama bilinçsizce.
Öyle geçti.
Tabii bu olurken
farklı konumlara, boyutlara,
koordinatlara gitmiş olduğum için
sufilerin anlattığı fil öyküsü gibi,
bilenleriniz vardır,
her defasında file
başka yerden dokunmaktır bu.
Bir körün file dokunması böyle bir şeydir.
"Ne kadar çok tekrar tekrar
file dokunursak,
fili o kadar anlarız"ı
özetler aslında bu hikâye.
Ben de gezdikçe aslında hayatı
daha iyi hissetmeye başladığımı fark ettim
herkes gibi tabii ki.
Tabii ki insanı etkileyen,
insanı var eden bir sürü faktör var.
Bunları ben kabaca üç grupta toparladım.
Birincisi genetik faktörler;
ben ona fabrika diyorum,
yani anam babam beni üretti.
Orada tabii ki coğrafya, iklim vesaire
gibi etkenler var.
Ardından toplumsal faktörler çıktı:
din, ahlak, dil vesaire vesaire.
Yani tasarımcılar beni tasarladı.
Bu tasarımdan sonra ben fabrikada
üretilmiş, tasarlanmış ürün olarak çıktım
ve kendimi güncellemeye başladım.
Bu da işte günlük faktörler, tabii ki
bunun içine çevre faktörleri,
eğitim, arkadaşlıklar vesaireler
eklenmeye başladı zaman içerisinde
ve böylece kişi kendini şekillendiriyor,
ben de öyle yaptım.
Otuz yıl bu şekilde geçti.
Geçtikten sonra tabii ki gördüm ki
bazen büyüdüm, bazen küçüldüm.
Bazen iyiydi, bazen kötü.
Ego kabardı, her şey benim için
yapıldı hissine kapıldım;
bazen de eyvah zavallıyım ben,
kimse bana bakmıyor gibi
herkes gibi tabii ki, gitmeler gelmeler
yani küçülmeler büyümeler oldu.
Ta ki işte o gün, otuz yaşlarımda
bir gün bale dersinde
yere otururken bağdaş kurmuş,
bale yapan arkadaşlarımı izlerken
bir baktım kendime sorular soruyorum:
Ben neredeyim? Niye bu dansı yapıyorum?
Benim arzum ne, bale mi gerçekten?
Batı dansıyla ben nereye gideceğim,
gibi sorular sorarken
bir fark ettim ki,
içimdeki ses bana diyor ki,
"Ben olsaydım kendi dansımı yaparım."
Ve orada jeton düştü
ve ben o sesi takip ettim.
İşte o gün bugün, geçen süre içerisinde
kendi geçmişime, kültürüme döndüm
ve lisanımı oluşturdum.
Dönüşü keşfettim
ve dönüş benim hayatım oldu.
Tabii ki yıllarca döne döne farklı
yerlerde, bu progress'e maruz kaldı
şüphesiz ki güncellemek gerekiyor çünkü.
Dervish in Progress benim lisanım oldu
ve öyle bir lisan ki bu,
ben bunu kendim için,
kendi hayatımı inşa etmek için kullandım.
Çünkü bence yaşamak sanattır,
biz de hayatımızın kendi sanatçısıyız.
O yüzden ben kendi kararlarımı
kendim vermeliyim.
Bu yüzden, Dervish in Progress'i
sanatsal bir araç olarak görmeye başladım
ve bugün burada bunu sizinle bunu
paylaşmaktan da büyük bir keyif alıyorum.
Şimdi, bu geçen bahsettiğim
bağdaş kurmadan sonra başlayan hayatta
döne döne dünyanın
bir sürü yerine gittim,
bir sürü tabloda gördüğünüz gibi
temsiller, workshop'lar, yüzlerce seyahat,
ondan sonra onlarca ülke ve proje,
kooperasyonlar yapıldı.
Bunların da ortalaması gördüğünüz gibi
yılda, son on bir yılın ortalaması
35 seyahat, 42 temsil, 32 workshop günü
ve 14 ülke ziyaret edildi
son 11 yıl içerisinde.
Düşünün ne kadar çok başa geldi.
Yani yılın en azından
150-200 günü yollarda geçti.
Bu olunca tabii ki,
öyle bir yere geliyorsunuz ki,
"Vaov! Hayat ne kadar kocamanmış!
Deniz derya..." diye hissediyorsunuz.
Her şey benimmiş gibi görünüyor bazen,
bazen de dediğim gibi bir kayboluyorsunuz.
İşte orada Hayyam geliyor aklıma:
"Bilge, yüce varlığın seyrine dalar;
gafilse onda dostluk düşmanlık arar.
Deniz, deniz olduğu için çalkalanır,
Çöpe sor, onun içindir bütün dalgalar."
İşte böyleyiz, küçücük bir çöpüz
ve dalgalanıyoruz bu evrende.
Şurada gördüğünüz resimde olduğu gibi,
bir sürü boyutun içinde küçücüğüz.
Ama bu küçükler de bir araya gelince
dev oluyorlar ve bu çok önemli.
O yüzden sürekli kendimizi
güncellememiz gerekiyor,
yani algılarımızı aralıksız
açıyor olmamız lazım.
Bu niyetle, gelin hep beraber
algı açmayı deneyelim.
Burada gördüğünüz gibi, mesela GAMA
ve Radyo çizgisini düşünecek olursak
yani elektromanyetik dalgayı
düşünecek olursak...
Bu arada hemen şunu da söyleyeyim:
bir sanatçıyım evet,
ama mühendis yanım
daha çok sahnede oldu hayatımda.
Burada da gördüğünüz üzere.
Gama ve radyo düşünecek olursak,
ışık bu elektromanyetik dalgada
sadece çok küçük bir bölümcük.
Yani işte hatırladığım kadarıyla,
aşağı yukarı yedi yüzle üç yüz dört yüz
nanometre arasındaki küçük dilimcik ışık.
Biz de ışık sayesinde gördüklerimizi
görüyoruz ve biz buna hayat diyoruz.
Gerisi de "yoooo" diye düşünüyoruz,
hâlbuki var ve bizim var diye
dediğimiz bu zahirî görünen şey,
aslında bu sonsuzluğun
sadece bir yüzü, bir noktası.
Bunu unutmamak lazım.
Sadece bu zihin algı açıklığını
yapabilmek için,
gelin hep birlikte hacim düşünelim,
mekân düşünelim.
İşte insan olarak biz ne yaparız,
en çok dünya gezileri yapabiliriz.
En büyük seyahatlerimiz bugüne kadar
bu oldu bazı astronotlar dışında.
Yani biz birkaç bin
kilometreden bahsedebiliriz,
on bin kilometre en çok olur bu.
Yani dünya kadar işte, on iki bin metre.
ama buradan Dünya'yla aramızdaki
mesafeyi düşünürseniz,
yüz elli milyon kilometre.
Bunu hayal bile etmemiz güç,
o yüzden algımızı açmamız gerekiyor.
Düşünün ki,
bu bir buçuk kilometrelik bir mesafe
bahsettiğim yüz elli milyon kilometre.
O zaman,
Dünya sadece bir portakal büyüklüğünde,
daha büyük değil
ve bu bir astronomik birim.
Güneş sistemi, aşağı yukarı
elli astronomik birim.
Ardından işte galakside bir sürü sistem,
evrenin içinde de bir sürü galaksi var.
Aynı açınmayı gelin zamanda da yapalım.
Evrenin ömrü 13.7 milyar yıl.
Bunu algılamamız mümkün değil,
ama yine de şu spagat açmayı
deneyelim zihnimizde.
Bunu zaman olarak, pardon mesafe olarak
kilometre olarak düşünecek olursak,
yani on 13.700 kilometreyi hayal edin.
Buradan Amerika kadar bir mesafe düşünün,
10-15 saat uçuş süresi.
O zaman bütün insanlık,
homo-sapiens'den
bugüne kadar sadece iki yüz metre.
İsa iki metre.
Muhammed bir buçuk metre.
Ben 4.7 santimetreyim.
Yani kabaca düşünecek olursam,
aslında bir bütün tarih eğer bir yılsa,
insan ömrü aşağı yukarı bir saniye.
Algımız açılsın diye bütün bu örnekler.
İşte bu tür şeyleri yaptıkça,
yani sığ dünyadan
yani şeriat bilgisinden
birazdan oraya geleceğim,
tarikata oradan hakikate
marifete gittikçe bu derinleşme oldukça,
sığ benlik derin benliğe doğru
kaymaya başlıyor.
Yani yaşadığımız biçmin
sadece bir biçim olduğu
ve bunun sonsuz varyasyonları
olabileceği fikri doğmaya başlıyor.
Yani ben,
sığ benlikten derin benliğe kayabiliyorum.
Fakat bazı değerlerle,
işte burada örnek olarak ego,
kıskançlık, aldatma, tembellik koydum.
Bunlarla biz hareket
ettiğimizde sığlaşıyoruz,
yani "ignorance," cehâlet
işin içine girince sığlaşıyor şüphesiz ki.
Ama tam tersi; bilgi, çalışkanlık,
işte dürüstlük, mütevazilikle bizim
derinleşmemiz de şüphesiz ki mümkün.
İşte bütün bu bilgiler ışığında yaşadıkça
17 yılı geçirip ilerledikçe bu hayatta,
47 yaşıma vardığım şu tarihte,
bunları bir şekilde toparlayabildiğim için
çok çok mutluyum.
Ve şunu da hemen eklemek üzere,
Şeriat, tarikat, hakikat, marifet;
suffizmin basamakları olarak hepimizin,
ya da en azından çoğumuzun
bildiği bu basamaklar katmanlar,
aslında başka mistiklerde
kendini gösteriyor.
Burada gördüğünüz Hristiyan
mistizminde olduğu gibi.
Lectio, meditatio,
contemplatio ve oratio şeklinde.
Yani önce ne olursa olsun, ne yapıyoruz;
önce üniversiteye gidiyoruz,
eğitimimizi tamamlıyoruz.
Şeriat aslında bilgi bütünü,
başka bir şey değil.
Biz bugün bunun anlamını
daraltmış durumdayız,
Arap kökenli olduğum için biliyorum bunu.
Kelime anlamıyla, bilgi bütünüdür.
Sonra üniversiteyi bitirirsiniz,
gidersiniz kendi
muayenehanenizi açarsınız;
işte o zaman tarikattır,
kendi yolunuza gittiniz.
Ama muayenehane açmak da yetmiyor,
hakikati anlamak gerekiyor "Niye doktorum
ben, nereye gidiyorum?" diye.
Kafayı yordukça bir gün
"Aha! Bu yüzden..." deyip jeton düşüyor,
afyon patlıyor,
nihâyet "Yes!" falan, "Evet oldu!"
İşte o zaman gerçekten
daha derin benliğe, marifete,
paylaşmaya, büyümeye gidiyor insan.
Yani işte son basamak,
son katman marifete gidiyoruz.
Aynı şekilde işte orratioya,
yani konuşmaya nihayetinde varıyoruz.
Konuşmaya başlıyoruz.
Bu katmanların içinde derinleştikçe
tabii ki derin benliğe;
ama yukarıda kaldıkça da,
sığ benliğe daha yakın
bir hayat sürmüş oluyoruz.
Bu böyle olunca,
görüyorsunuz ki aslında insan
sürekli kendisini güncelliyor.
Eski formatları bir şekilde bırakıyor,
yenileri eklemeye çalışıyor.
Yenileri eklendikçe format değişiyor,
yani güncelleme devam ediyor.
Fabrika ayarlarında kalmıyoruz,
güncelliyoruz kendimizi
ve bu çok güzel, o kadar güzel ki;
aynen Mevlana'nın söylediği gibi,
"Düne ait ne varsa,
dünde kaldı cancağızım.
Bugün yeni şeyler söylemek lazım."
(Alkış)
Teşekkür ederim.
İşte bu niyetle,
dönüş beni dönüştürdü;
dönmüş hâlimle,
dönüşmüş hâlimle kafa yorup
güncellemeye çalıştım dönüş bilgisini
ve Dervish in Progress oldu.
Bunun bir kılavuzu var,
buraya sığmayacak ama birkaç cümleyle
özetlemeye çalışacağım.
Öncelikle bilmeniz gerekir ki,
dönüş dünyasına girmek demek
yeni bir fiziğe maruz kalmak demek.
Yani nasıl daldığınızda
suyun altında nefes almayacağınızı,
suyun sizi kaldıracağını biliyorsanız,
arabaya bindiğinizde
hızınızın olduğunu biliyorsanız,
dönüşe girdiğinizde bilesiniz ki
merkezkaç kuvvetinin
etkisinde olacaksınız.
Siz döndükçe bütün algılarınız,
algılar değişmeye başlayacak.
Gözlerin görüş biçimi,
kulakların dengeyi sağlaması,
hızın hissi vesaire değişmeye başlayacak.
Beş duyu, bilgiyi farklı türlü
toplamaya başlayacak.
Bu da beynin bilmediği bir şey olduğundan,
kafası karışmaya başlayacak.
Bu yüzden temel bilgiler çok önemli.
Göz normal görmeyecek,
denge bozulacak,
hız algısı değişecek,
bilgilerini unutmadan bilgisayarda
yeni bir programlama yaparmışcasına
yeni software programlarcasına,
siz dönüş fiziğini anlamanız öğrenmeniz
ve kaydetmeniz gerekiyor.
Bu yüzden bu temel bilgiler çok önemli.
İkinci temel bilgiler de,
eğer temel bilgileri anlamış
ve gidiyorsanız,
işte o zaman iyi bir şoför oluyorsunuz.
Umarım sesim daha önce de duyuluyordu.
Eğer aracın nasıl sürüleceğini
öğrendiysek, şoför olduysak,
bir de iyi şoför olabiliriz.
Temel bilgiler işte bu yüzden.
Yani ben hareketi yaparken kaslarımı
ve kemiklerimizi açarsam,
bütün sistemlerin optimal bir şekilde
çalışmasını sağlamış olurum.
Buna ek olarak stresimi azaltırsam,
enerji harcamayı azaltmış olurum.
Üstüne güzelce bir solunum yaparsam da,
çok enerji üretme imkanım olur.
Yani iyi şoför olurum.
İyi şoför;
bilgiyi zaten öğrenmişim,
o zaman dönerim beni kimse tutamaz.
Özetle; Temel Bilgiler 1'i A dersem,
2'ler de B ise,
Dönüşü de D ile simgelersem...
Bir üniversitedeyiz,
A artı B eşittir ne olur?
"Ben dönerim" olur.
Bunu herkes yapabilir,
yüceltmenin manası yok.
Yüzyıllar içerisinde çok uzaklaştırdılar
bizi birbirimizden.
Dönenler yüceltildi biz burada kaldık,
o yüzden dönemeyiz diye düşünüyoruz.
Yalan!
Yok öyle bir şey.
Şimdi, bu ne oluyor? Dönünce ne oluyor?
Solunum hızlandığı için
enerji üretimim hızlanıyor,
enerji ürettiğim için
sinir sistemim aktive oluyor,
daha fazla bilgiye elektrik gidiyor.
Biliyorsunuz, nöronlar snepsler yapıp
bilgi telcikleri oluşuyor zihnimizde.
Bunların hepsi kayıt.
Bunların hepsine elektrik gidince;
geçmişi, geleceği, fanteziyi,
her şeyi hissetmeye başlıyorsunuz.
Dolaşım sistemi hızlanıyor,
işte malzeme transferi hızlanıyor.
Ondan sonra, hormonlardaki değerler
değişmeye başlıyor.
Siz işte daha fazla hormon salgıladığınız
için üzülüyorsunuz, ağlıyorsunuz,
heyecanlanıyorsunuz vesaire vesaire.
Ciddi bir değişim oluyor bedende.
İşte bunların hepsini ben;
17 yıllık sahne tecrübem,
ama aynı zamanda da,
on küsür yıldır da verdiğim
derslerden yaptığım çıkarımlardır.
Bu ne oluyor aslında sonuçta,
ben şunu yapıyorum:
Sığ benliğimi, yani işte bu dünyadaki,
zahirî dünyadaki, görünür dünyadaki beni,
yani cahil beni,
bir şekilde iç dünyaya,
yani derin benliğe götürüp
orada soyutlaştırıp, duygusallaştırıp,
paylaşımcı hale getirip,
başka bir boyuta getirerek
büyütme imkânı yaratmış oluyorum.
Sonuçta bu nasıl oluyor;
işte yaptığım fiziksel, düşünsel
ve duygusal mobilizasyonla.
Yani tekrar özetleyecek olursak;
sığ benlik, yani işte zahirî dediğimiz
o dış dünyadaki şekilci, çıkarcı ben,
pratikle derin benin içine girerek
döne döne döne döne,
paylaşımcı olmaya, aynı zamanda
duygusal olmaya başlıyor.
Yani batıniyi anlamaya başlıyor
daha büyüğü.
İşte aslında bizim de koştuğumuz,
peşinde koştuğumuz yapı da
bunun ikisinin bütünü olan "tüm benlik".
Yani terazinin iki kefesindeki
bu iki oluş biçimini
dengeleyebileceğimiz
bir formatın peşindeyiz.
Yani vahdet,
yani tek, yani bilge,
yani kâmil, insanı kâmil dediğimiz
şeyin peşindeyiz.
Bu ölçülü yapıdır.
Bunu da formüle edecek olursam;
cahilden C, gafilden G,
toplam insanı kâmil.
C artı G eşittir K.
Benim, Dervish in Progress'te de
yaptığım şey aslında
D ile, yani dönüş ile
insanı kâmile, yani K'ya gitmek.
(Alkış)
Şimdi, burada size sormak isterim.
Ne yapmalı şu görünür dünyada,
zahirî dünyada?
Cahil, çıkarcı, şekilci kalmak mı;
yoksa tüm benliğe gidip,
insanı kâmil olup,
duygusallaşıp terazinin kefelerini
dengeleyip, insanı kâmil olmak mı?
Tercih sizin.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)